mais ça revient pour la dixième année
mon cher max et le 20 septembre et en
retour attendu dix nouveaux candidats
toujours animé par camille combal et
karine ferri
alors on rappelle les unes derrières
l'audience avait augmenté par rapport à
la saison précédente 4 million deux cent
mille donc grosse attente sur cette
nouvelle saison de danse avec les stars
elles avaient remonté à l'égard des
sanguins étaient redescendus de charles
et de diana était remonté bon d'accord
mais tous les ans à la rentrée c'est la
même petite ritournelle qui tourne dans
nos têtes
et oui danse avec les stars fête sa
dixième saison anniversaire dans
quelques jours salut ça va
une ambiance dauphin passé et comme tous
les ans le casting du blockbuster de tf1
est très très attendu alors que vaut-il
cette saison qui sont les nouveaux shy'm
matt pokora ou ryan métiers de la promo
c'est ce qu'on va voir dans cette petite
revue d'effectif avant d'entrer en piste
on commence par les stars les plus
connues la chanteuse et humoriste vienne
folie c'est magnifique
la vedette de téléréalité et ancien
candidat culte de koh lanta moundir
tf1 prend même des risques cette année
en incorporant la très jolie mais
sulfureuse clara morgane à son programme
familial
un choix qui doit faire plaisir à
certains je dis oui parmi les
personnalités un peu moins connus on
retrouve le mannequin hugo philippe
qu'on a déjà vu dans les bras de
caroline receveur
le journaliste de l'équipe 21 johan riou
le nageur paralympique sami el gueddari
ont encore le jeune acteur aziz diabaté
alors selon vous le casting 2019 de
danse avec les stars est il à la hauteur
et surtout va-t-il permettre à des
missions de faire remonter les audiences
en constante baisse chaque saison c'est
vrai que sur le découpage édition il ya
un petit changement ce qui a favorisé
une meilleure audience très bon effet
une façon comme une autre de travailler
un peu mon travail avec les pauvres
c'est bien le voilà alors oui qu'est ce
qui se passe je suis très excité tir je
suis vraiment très excité mais vraiment
on par rapport à cette émission je suis
excité souvent général hélas cette
émission pourquoi parce que j'étais très
inquiet claudie vous en parler je trouve
le casting très intelligent j'aime
beaucoup l'idée qu'on revoie moundir
avant une grande chaîne je pense qu'il
va avoir tout les jeunes avaient quand
on a hâte de le voir on a le devoir en
tant que danseuse voir ce qu'il a à
faire et je suis sûr qu'il va nous faire
rire oui bon mais on en parle de seconde
de moundir ok on va quand même décerner
une médaille à w9
est-ce que moundir c'est quand même
moundir et des apprentis et le mec il
appelle la chaîne edi à l'eau et bonjour
c'est me dire je vais sur tf1 faire dans
cette liste à ya pas de problème mais
non lieu quasi exclusivité ce cas lui
permettent d'aller sur tf1 olivier minne
qui était sur france 2 avait fait de
recycler ça avait posé de problème à
personne sauf que oui mais est présent
sur france 2 mais franchement mounir sur
w9 c'est un programme phare c'est être
celui là
mieux mais c'est très intelligent de
s'imaginer le coup de projecteur pour
son programme
d'autant qu'ils se sont non plus jamais
caché que ce problème avait été un peu
pompé de koh lanta alors non
énergétiques et libertés dans vos it out
je peux juste terminée avérée plus
élevée moi ce que sa part s'est passé
sur mon lit
visiblement la baie en super sympa gamou
dire y'a johan riou que certains
connaissent peu mais que les promesses
irakien qui est sûre l'équipe et qui
s'excuse mais attention parce que
justement on va le découvrir les
personnages aussi on french and de très
bons pour le cas j'adore clara morgane
aussi j'ai vraiment de la voirie pour
sexy et il faut pas oublier que
maintenant il ya double ration de people
puisque les de leurs actions bah oui
double ration figuration à son ration
comme c'est comme le double chocolat
non mais parce que maintenant même les
danseurs sont connus on les a vus toute
l'année dans les magazines people
c'est long quand même aussi aux
personnes handicapées dans tout ça très
bien on sera c'est le seul coup de coeur
que j'ai après excuse moi francesca mais
franchement j'ai noté parce que je me
souviens même pas vas-y celle opérée où
c'est qu'ils en veulent je sais pas qui
c'est c'est pas une star fait qu'il est
dense avec du soudard lis ça me fait un
champion paralympique moi c'est une star
tu vas mourir tu va l'adorer
je cherche pas à route à trouver des
stages est le regard des gens veulent en
voir donc si tu veux il correspond pas
au casting
après un gros coup de coeur aussi pour
elsa est ce nous qui est une star exact
d'où elle est bien connue du public
on va jon sim et c'est un carton chez
les jeunes elle car je connais ni l'une
ni l'autre
j'en ai parlé
à dire vrai je veux vendre la grosse
baril va coûter continue à proposer ou
non seulement 6 police a fait 10 ans
mais cette année là mais c'est la gagne
oui c'est bien de folie qui va gagner
cette année vous verrez si les brèves un
très petit casting faut dire la vérité
aux gens non c'est un tout petit casting
et nous j'ai pas choisi personnes j'ai
trouvé le deuxième tout le monde leur a
dit non donc ils se sont rabattus sur
ceux qui voulaient bien venir ils ont
pris comme d'habitude beaucoup de gens
qui sont liés au sport et qui vont très
vite disparaître
et surtout comme d'habitude tout et
marketé c'est à dire qu'on sait déjà que
denis de sa ket la star danseuses du
programme doit aller très loin
sauf qu'ils l'ont mis avec aziz qui lui
est une star entre guillemets diabaté
les drass les rouges
tous les deux vont aller très loin donc
comme d'habitude tout est organisé
mark était structuré décidé à l'avance -
contrairement à francesca ça ne m'excite
pas d'accord ça vous avez 6 pancarte
vous pose vite le casting est à la
hauteur de nos côtes en attendant
totalement et oui c'est trois ou quatre
candidats inconnus au bataillon lequel
six était moins attendu maxime appart
rocade ils ont disloqué de la merde elle
exactement la même stratégie qu aux
états-unis bien sont quasiment à la 30e
saison et vous regardez le casting n'y a
pas de grandes saisons et a quasiment
way back ma vie elle exactement et il
n'y a pas de grandes stars y ait des
vedettes ici et là de télé réalité des
journalistes exactement la même logique
fois goûté on donne à fond de voix
libérales en l1 parce qu'il ya de tuya
vigo philippe pour les 13 je recherchais
tout le monde contre elle moi je ne vais
regarder que pour liane foly
c'est très mal gré plutôt peut-être pas
d'ailleurs ça mais ce que vous regardez
dans cest que les stars pas trop mais
c'est sa diversité qui ya là dedans moi
ça me plaît ça vous plaît ah bah voilà
donc le voile a repris le café guillain
barré golden marche c'est bon on s'en
fout là finissait le programme dense
avec l'exacte e mans
la raison c'est léo les gens qui
viennent faire cette émission viennent
pour avoir la notoriété c'est devenu
danse avec les inconnus on mettrait ce
serait plus sympa d'ailleurs d'avoir des
seins qu'elle est connu mais non c'est
hic c'est que maintenant il faut c'est
une vanne non non je suis très content
parce qassam
c'est un très grand bien que la tendance
oui oui en plus il est beau et bon comme
je vois pas morgan non mais moi je
trouve que le casting comme damian je la
rejoins liane foly pour laisser plus
âgées pour la ménagère il ya également
elsa est ce nous avec qui je partage la
fiction les mystères de la touche notre
cible via moundir pour la télé réalité
moi je trouve que le casting est
vraiment complet est vraiment top
maintenant le petit souci chez se trouve
que les danseurs sont plus tard que les
starsky et participe au bout d'un moment
il ya tant qu'ils font très
intelligemment c'est le teasing sur les
réseaux sociaux mis au jour en soit si
vous suivez vous me direz tout ça ils
n'arrêtent pas même le générique et la
pub